la Bibliothèque Départementale de la
Réunion durant les années 1930
l'architect publ réunionnaise s'inspire
des styles àor Envog en Indochine et à
Madagascar premier édifice culturel
construit à la Réunion la Bibliothèque
départementale en est l'un des plus
beaux témoignages hébergé chez un
particulier puis dans l'une des salles
de l'hôtel de VE de Saint-Denis la
bibliothèque coloniale s'installe en
1937 dans un bâtiment spécialement conçu
par l'ingénieur Antoine telmar ce nouvel
édifice abrite quelques c000 documents
patrimoniaux
sa façade principale donne sur la rue
Roland Garos parmi les nombreux détails
contribuant à son élégance les volets
perienés et les refants qui se jouent de
la lumière au fil de la
journée avec ses 24 m de long sur 8 de
large la salle de lecture est sans
conteste la pièce la plus imposant de la
bibliothèque l'aile contemporaine
inauguré en 2009 a permis de multiplier
par 2 et demi la superficie de cet
équipement
d'exception alliance de tradition et de
modernité elle est l'œuvre de
l'architecte de
niipul matériaux traditionnel ici
revisité le béton brut est partiellement
recouvert de feuilles de
cuivre nouvel accès à la bibliothèque ce
vaste parallèle épipède de 41 m
accueille entre autres des ateliers pour
les scolaires et les chercheurs et le
dépôt légal
omniprésent le verre est à la fois
source de lumière jeu d'ombre et de
miroir cette extension contemporaine a
donné un nouveau souffle à ce bâtiment
du conseil général ancêtre de toutes les
bibliothèques de
Lille